Speaker 1: This is a really interesting sign.
A whole bunch of Republicans who won their
2022 primaries wiped mentions of failed former
President Donald Trump from their websites after
their primary as they reset their campaigns for
the general election in November. This signals an
arguably significant change within the Republican
electorate, at least as far as the candidates are
perceiving. So let's talk about it. There's a
good Daily Beast article by Sam Brody, who's a
congressional reporter, which points out and is
titled Republican Candidates Strip Abortion and
Trump Connections from their Campaign Websites.
These Republicans have made a calculation. They
made the calculation during the primary among
the Republican electorate. It's good to play
up our connection to Trump in our support of
Donald Trump. Once they won their primary,
their view changed and they said, okay, for the
general election electorate, I am now better off
removing mentions of Donald Trump. And I think
when we look at exactly who these candidates are,
it will start to make a lot of sense. And we're
going to link to this article and you can check
it out. And I'm getting a paywall and let me
just see if I can deal with that so that we can
actually look at the article that popped up all
of a sudden. And because of clarity, I really want
to. Here we go. Okay. Right after Beau Hynes won
a crowded primary from Congress in North Carolina,
a visitor to the campaign website would
immediately find his declaration that he was 100%
pro-life and 100% pro-Trump. Pretty clear. A click
away was a section focused on life and family,
which professed Hines position that life begins
at conception. Naturally, the first thing greeting
any visitor to the site was the grinning face
of Trump. And it is all gone, gone, gone, gone.
And the article points out that all of that stuff,
all of those invocations and images of Donald
Trump, they've all been removed, except for one
apparently photoshopped image with Hines in the
section on border security. This is not the first
person who did this. The Daily Beast reviewed a
bunch of different websites for 2022 Republican
candidates and found that at least five House
Republican candidates in battleground districts
completely wiped or scrubbed mentions of Trump
or the 2020 election from their websites or social
media right after winning the primaries. At least
seven removed or significantly modified language
about abortion on their websites over the summer.
At least three have scrubbed their online pages
of Trump. That includes Blake Masters of Arizona,
Mehmet Oz of Pennsylvania, Tiffany Smiley of
Washington, and at least two did the same for
abortion, Blake Masters and Adam Laxalt. So, as
the article says, generally it's uncommon to see.
And that it's significantly changed platforms in
branding during the course of a campaign. Some
of them are saying, well, we just redirect. We
just redesigned the website. That's all we did.
Others are saying, well, we reshuffled the content
to other places, but we know exactly what is going
on here. There is a recognition among many of
these Republican candidates that, number one, the
hard line anti-abortion positions are out of step
with the American public. We know that all polling
shows us that over the last 50 years, what we call
the Roe v Wade era, over the period of the Roe v
Wade era. The country has moved in the direction
of abortion being legal to those who want it in
most cases. And this really came to a head with
the Supreme Court's reversal of Roe v Wade with
guaranteed abortion as a right, in most cases
to women. This is now causing a problem for some
Republicans. And the way some of them are dealing
with it is getting rid of the hardcore anti-choice
language from their websites. But there's a second
bigger recognition as well. The guy that will help
you win among the Republican electorate may
actually hurt you in the general election. And
we're talking, of course, of Donald Trump. This
is, to some degree a change from previous years.
You know, we often laugh about Trump takes credit
for his endorsement record. And that record really
isn't quite as good as he claims it to be. But
the truth is that it was pretty good for a while,
and it no longer is seen as the sort of unabashed
advantage that it was at one point. We will see
how these folks do in November, and then
we will see what that means for 2024.